hey move here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and I'm doing another
knife-making project I'm going to show
you how to make a knife from a piece of
all thread this is that threaded bar you
get at the hardware store and this is
the knife
I made the sheath and handle the whole
shebang and the cool part about this
project is the only power tool I use
with an angle grinder so this is
something you can do if you don't know a
lot of tools you could do this on a
budget I even made the forge myself for
less than $200
[Applause]
yeah getting those blue flames from the
galvanization burning off on the
all-thread
[Music]
kind of drippy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh time is ticking
[Music]
Hey
it's still really hot right now very
slowly it's already done a really good
job
yeah moving that out they got that
straight edge effect now the tool that
real knife this has is like a bench
grinder and you know it's just so much
you need to get nice flat consistent
angle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now we're going to heat treat this
sucker
you know some huntin
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no it's the warm drink it's British yeah
they don't tell their beer yeah new your
pictures are nasty
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
something
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know this is just a really fun
project I mean I just love the smithing
marks on this thing and now you can see
the all thread pattern still in the
blade it's just really simple and you
know I'm no match blacksmith I need
stretch of the imagination but I really
like this knife it was just a super fun
project and you know it
it'll touch it is no katana but it works
so anyway thanks for watching if you
want to see more videos like this check
out the outdoor boys YouTube channel and
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos every week thanks for
watching